sheriff I've got one more issue I want
to talk to you about before we say
goodbye to you I want to get your
reaction about a report out tonight over
an alleged incident between you and a
passenger on a flight to Milwaukee this
took place almost a year ago the
Milwaukee Journal Sentinel is reporting
the FBI got involved and there is this
document that I've actually read
exonerating you from the Department of
Justice but while there are no charges
the passenger has filed a civil lawsuit
against you I would like to get your
take on it
well it's a frivolous lawsuit and it has
yet to be adjudicated so I can't say too
much but this is a fake news story
I don't know how Donald Trump feels to
be the subject of fake news from the
liberal media as you indicated I sent
you the letter they found no wrongdoing
that case is closed and I was informed
of that last May so here we are in
December and they're trying to read igg
this story rehash it with allies
interwoven in between it to make it seem
like this is something new there was no
wrongdoing I was doing good police work
at the time and I think the United
States Attorney's Office recognized that
and that's why they said there was no
evidence of any wrongdoing sheriffing
burger sheriff I appreciate you being
here to Monique as well we wish you both
a happy happy new year